One of the ways to,
to kind of approach this,
according to a political analyst,
is to actually have open discourse,
to talk about it in real life
and not just online
where people are fighting one another.
It's, it is through what they call
under the realm of good governance,
it's called participatory governance.
When you actually let people
participate in the government and have a say in this,
and not just the people who are informed about it.
It includes
people who just watch dance videos in TikTok.
Everyone should have a say in this.
That can be done through barangay level.
It can be done through facilitating discussions
and open and honest discussion,
education on both sides.
That is one of the ways to approach
constitutional reform
for a country that is mistrustful,
that has been traumatized.
The way to move forward from this
is with making it as understandable as possible
and not just through fear,
not just through rushing things,
and which I think is a common mistake, is it's,
the way that it's being done is either through bribery
or it's through just very dramatic declarations.
Create a culture where progress is not feared.
It is something to be excited about,
something to think about.